foreign
where are you ready
from Under Armor came out to the park
and enjoying the bullpen picnic area you
guys having fun having a [ __ ] great
time
wow uh so were you like everyone else
and watched a lot of Jamie Oliver on
[Applause]
I'm getting crispy
[Applause]
I'm getting crispy sorry
and I tell you it's very safe it's
durable and it's like carrying me oh
really
wow now it's locked in place okay so
really you say oh God Harold are you
okay actually I didn't have it locked
you have to lock it once you lock it
you're okay
71 year old man is accused of an
appropriately touching a 12 year old
girl at the Walmart in West Mifflin
Sunday afternoon a ninth anniversary in
Hugh Janus turning 10. we had mentioned
I'm sorry
it's one of those it's one of those
I totally felt more didn't I bumbling
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I live in LA and I heard it's gonna rain
three times this week so that's pretty
oh my God
pretty oh my God
[Music]
understand
[Music]
[Laughter]
Tony one two three four five
one two three four five miles news shows
so often you know and those new shows
are terrible Tony I'm telling you I just
realized it because I'm hearing the new
show in the background now you always
think that you're doing those good
morning shows but this is one of those
news shows Kim I'm telling you this is
crazy I don't want to do this
Tony I'm going to be part of the local
news how exciting
[Music]
Tony Danza
we never know when people are listening
to what you're saying Tony
[Music]
Tony Dance I'm so excited
[Music]
okay Tony can you hear me now yes I can
okay we're going to start the interview
now no murder in Mayhem just the
interview about your movie you ready all
right fine oh you heard me huh oh every
bit of it oh good joining us now is Tony
Danza you know him well don't you feel
it I mean don't you feel a little bit
like that's what you do I mean not
just me who thinks that by the way go
ahead all right I don't know how I make
my living so yeah
I'm just saying you can't just don't
deny it you know please I don't care you
should make a living I think that's fine
okay
[Laughter]
one of the first things I do in a case
Lisa is I always make sure people know
that if I feel the person is living or
not so you'll always know when you talk
to a family member when you start a case
you'll know if this person is dead or
alive and that's the point is that every
time Lori I'm going to show you
something okay
okay
yes does this girl look familiar Tia she
does
I work this case this is a girl
who you said
was beaten
and killed
okay this little girl is me
and you told somebody that she's dead
wait a minute
you didn't disappear
I'm right here
well that's interesting isn't it how do
you explain being complete I can't
explain it I can't explain it you're
charging them hundreds of dollars you
know what dear hundreds of dollars
you're taking advantage of desperate
people with a bunch of Hocus Pocus
aren't you no I'm not I think we'll go
thank you it's been an interesting
experience
you all have loved me love you
[Music]
we're down
[Music]
mine says that it's four quarters for an
hour but a quarter only gets you 15
minutes so if my math is correct that's
not an hour that's not an hour but it is
and also a quarterback
rewind take that off take that off
you're right 15 minutes is a cool
I swear to God I do not do drugs I have
not had liquor
thank you very much for for this for
giving me this and I appreciate my
friends also my wife and my girlfriend I
mean my wife yeah sorry to say
I'm so I'm so sorry my wife lizzo I love
you so much Aya I love you so much from
my heart so you must keep on supporting
me and thanks for for to come to the
game take a look at birthdays and
anniversaries in the meantime happy 80th
birthday to e Norma Stitz
um Quitman happy birthday to you Miss
enorma hope you have a wonderful day
Harry belvani joining us live this
morning from New York hey good morning
Harry
Harry wake up
Harry yeah
yes wake up wake up
this is your wake-up card
nothing okay
um I'll tell you what oh we are going
he's yeah he's meditating he's having
a single nap walking a little nap see
you see daylight we might wake he's okay
he is okay
Carol when it comes to the weather we
want no monkey business okay
well good thanks it's 49 degrees in
Philadelphia Nicole uh we have a
temperature of 30. you can't even give
me that can you uh well Carol I would
say that forecast is bananas but I know
that's something completely wasted on
you so I won't taking it back right now
he's gonna do something I don't
understand what he's up to now and you
really start to watch what's happening
that's the other thing about the humans
you have to pay attention to it
did a good job being big shots he did on
on the other hand we got some stops our
D was good tonight so we got to make
sure our D's thing good before the game
kept Bazemore told me it's too far into
the season to allow two losses back to
back if you agree with that how
important is that win oh it's very
important but it starts with the D so we
got hit we gotta make sure we keep
playing defense
we'll let you go back to you guys